were you more fired up for Sunday's game
in Atlanta or that halftime speech with
Florida State your Seminoles against Ole
Miss a couple of weeks ago uh I'm just
fired up to be around football you know
is I'm very excited that the season is
has finally kicked off or we can compete
and play the greatest game in America
how would you rate your halftime speech
haha now you know I can't really give it
a number i just it's just strictly from
the heart you know how much coach fisher
and those coaches coach Sanders have
done for me at for the state it just it
would not be in me to just be quiet and
not express my feelings to how we were
playing and what we can do to be to be
better in that and that halftime speech
well it's one thing to give a half time
speech could you actually coach the
Seminoles if you know Coach Fisher's
sicked out and you had to step in could
you do it I'm not no way in the word
that I could do do it coach Fisher does
but if they need some motivation if they
need somebody to lean on I definitely
would be there for me and that way
explain to me when coach cutter says
check down how many times does he say
that to you on Sunday check it down to
the backs he doesn't he doesn't say it
to me that much more practice but on
Sunday coach cutter he's in his own and
he just making sure that everyone is on
the same page you went to the no huddle
what's the difference with that and why
were you more successful I think just
his offense in general is just up tempo
office and uh and we like to go fast you
know going to ask race one thing it
helps us to start faster which I need to
get better at as far as starting star
performing faster in the in the first
quarter and the early minutes in the
game and also just helps us get into
rhythm you know any time the train you
in real
and I everyone's on the same page we're
hardened pop do you make Mike Evans look
better or does mike evans make you look
better my eris makes me look way better
did I make him look now you're just
David do you ever just say Mike just
just go long and I'll throw it uh not
really you know he's a great
route-runner but I tell them and Mike if
you beat them deep I'm just gonna throw
it up and you're gonna get like you
trust me I'm gonna go get it what's
different this year as opposed to your
rookie year I think I'm just more
comfortable in the system as far as last
year I had a lot to learn coach Carter
through the whole playbook at me and as
far as concept was I wasn't having to
learn a lot but just verbal verbal
verbal communication and a different
names of the calls I had to really just
harp on and really study so I didn't
miss any of them up but this year I'm
just very confident and more comfortable
in the office give me a give me a
complicated play call so we're at the
line of scrimmage but why okay we go
Diablo right atrium 76 of chief exits
and we're just as a freeze call I'm
trying to get a man's own read off to
running back and it's just the easy
progression now we have a lot of long
play calls yeah okay now obviously I
know something about playing quarterback
I played my freshman year in high school
so I can relate to some of this here
here yeah now we would always say on to
do you guys ever say it's on one or
first sound or why don't we do on hut
hut anymore or on to uh we do we do hut
hut oh yes sir we do but do you call it
you actually say on too well in the net
in net in net play actually can give
decadence after I make my first freeze
call so I'm basically gonna make a dummy
call hmm and then
offensive lineman decadence after seeing
what I need to seem to make the right
shape he's Jameis Winston of the
Buccaneers joining us do you have an
Omaha Omaha I do i do not have an Omaha
I don't think I've I've got to that
level of my case I gotta do need I need
to create me a a word but I don't have
Omaha I got one for you Orlando Orlando
Orlando that's right here the oh yeah
yeah we could do that we could get a
sponsorship Disney would sponsor it I'm
telling you can make some money here
Jameis man yes I liked what you think um
I is it weight loss or just in better
shape much was made of that in the
offseason um I think I think just a
cloud products a better shape I'm user
in better shape but I really view this
all season as just redefining my body as
far as I truly only lost eight pounds
this offseason and my weight really
fluctuates from time to time but I think
just having a constant routine this
being my first true offseason because I
always play baseball in offseason and
you can't really count of the combined
training as true offseason work because
you're strictly just trying to compete
you're trying to be at your highest
you're trying to peek into in two months
you know and that's kind of that's kind
of difficult especially you're coming
off a long season so this year I just I
had time to rest I had time to put in
actual work quality work that can
actually help me improve or my game
tougher to play quarterback in the NFL
or hit a baseball I think baseball and
playing quarterback is so so similar as
far as because we playing baseball has
always helped me to become a better
quarterback and even me playing
quarterback has helped me become a
better baseball player because if you
view if you do the quarterback position
as a hitter you think you make the
pre-snap breathe in that box you
thinking okay what am I going to get so
you got to get you have to pick your
pitch that you want and you got to be
ready
to swing at that picture in the time you
think that quarterback you gotta look at
the safeties identify the front and
assume the coverage that you're going to
get and you got to be ready for any
coverage that they throw at you just
like in that batter's box you might get
a fastball on the outside corner you
might get a SAM fife am at d from the
right side you might get a curveball you
know they might discover the coverage on
you well you got followers cover three
but they end up making it covered too
you know there's so many different
situations that you can just put those
hand in hand but in today you just got
to execute do you rule out baseball as a
career at home at any point uh I guess I
gotta say that right now this in a lot
of face off so much and i bet my
highlight of my year was being able to
throw the first pitch out at Eddie
Yankees various game so that was pretty
good for me what about it would you have
advice for Tim Tebow uh no advice I
believe Tim Tebow is just a great
competitor and I think you just you
still have that that that fire in him
you know and he's a god-fearing man so
entertained it that he puts his mind to
I know he's gonna trust in the Lord and
he's gonna find a way to be successful
either he's always had I know you worked
out with Jim Grover yeah did he ever
tell you Michael Jordan stories when he
was working young you know one thing
about mr. Grover man it's hard to get it
to get a bead on him you know because he
doesn't really give you a lot of stories
but the man is just a worker you know he
he doesn't really want to talk he
doesn't really allow me to take pictures
during my workout when people want to
work out with me he's strictly trying to
get our two hours of work in and we're
trying to Train like the best and that's
what he's about he's about being the
best how far can the buccaneers go this
year I think we can go as far as we want
you know and that's the thing about the
NFL the game is it's a week-to-week game
you know people people want to make it
about a long season no this is weak weak
you gotta worry about being 1 and 0 at
the end of the week last time I saw you
you had a Heisman Trophy in New York
City where is that I
uh my dad has it somewhere you know I
think I think when I had that Heisman
Trophy when I left New York that that's
probably the last time I seen it other
than seen in any cases at Florida State
because my dad has has really took that
off my hair wait wait so if your dad has
it but you don't know where he has it I
have no idea where he had you know he
treats that thing like you know so he's
always you know it's always a new place
you know you never know with my dad hey
congrats and good luck against Arizona
and thanks for joining us Jameis thank
you so much for having me I really
enjoyed the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience